et pour ça il faut ouvrir son cœur tu as
un bonheur
c'est un con que j'ai refusé tout des
interviews
radio presse télévision ça vous a manqué
oui et non oui pourquoi non pourquoi
parce que à la télévision il y a des
interviews
qui sont vachement marrants et que
j'aime bien j'aime bien l'agression
monsieur Baffie
parce que ça me fasses mal Laura non
mais ça me permet d'être un miroir si
les grossiers je deviens grossier si les
violences je deviens violents s'il est
adorable je suis adorable j'adore ça et
là qu'est-ce que tu prédis là je te
prédis
ta division là pour l'interview ma
voisine monsieur
[Musique]
c'était écrit quand je voyais c'était
écrit donc toujours habillé dans le
programme télé
quand vos amis essayent de vous faire un
chant à l'anniversaire surprise et tout
vous faites semblant parce qu'en fait
vous le savez avant
bien sûr
mais je ne fête jamais mes anniversaires
ni les fêtes c'était un interdit de ma
mère mon dernier indien anniversaire le
18 février je fuis la société parce que
j'avais entendu qu'ils allaient préparer
quelque chose et je suis passé me cacher
vous saviez qu'il préparait quelque
chose mais je suis pas Madame Irma ah
bon je n'ai pas de boule de cristal je
ne fais pas de la voyance je n'ai jamais
fait de la voyance je ne suis pas un
prophète je suis un exégète donc je
tente de d'expliquer les les prophéties
parfois je me plante qui fait flipper
tout le monde aussi à la station mirror
moi je travaillais avec des gens j'étais
à la radio ce soir là et mon équipe
flippait disait non mais attends c'est
dans 20 minutes vous déconner quoi les
gens ils flippent ils te rend pas compte
hein toi tu dis des conneries
moi je me déploqué
il y a des gens qui ont fait des enfants
trouver
est-ce que vous auriez pas préféré
finalement que la station Mir tombe sur
Paris et pas passer pour un con
honnêtement non non c'est très risqué ce
que je fais et si cela n'arrive pas je
vais me planter d'une façon magistrale
mais je n'accepte
et après j'ai rencontré à Moscou j'avais
tous les deux à Moscou les Russes de
services qui m'ont dit votre bouquin
nous a fait flipper et on a fait on a
mis énormément d'argent pour la faire
tomber là où elle est tombée parce
qu'ils avaient décrété qu'ils allaient
la laisser tomber n'importe où 56 ans en
tous les cas
56 ans
ça vous a enseigné l'humilité non on a
beaucoup beaucoup parce que je c'était
un coup de pied dans le cul magistral et
je me suis dit maintenant tu fermes ta
gueule mais c'est pas pour ça que je
veux pas continuer ce que cette
recherche spirituelle qui est l'essence
même de ma vie
pour moi essayez de comprendre pourquoi
on est sur le sur cette planète quelle
est notre destin comment pouvons-nous
améliorer notre vie en regardant autour
de nous c'est pour moi c'est Vita
essentiel il a raison pourquoi est-ce
qu'on est sur cette planète
ça passe vite le dimanche matin on
s'appelle pour les audiences ouais tu me
diras en même temps oui et vous vous
savez pourquoi on est sur cette planète
Rosie
sur la terre des êtres rien carnés parce
que je vois pas d'animal par mauvais ou
je vois pas de plantes je vois pas un
renard
non c'était quoi avant Orlando
c'était quoi avant dans notre vie tu
étais quoi aucune idée en tous les cas
vous avez pris une leçon du ciel qui
vous a fait beaucoup de bien beaucoup de
bien beaucoup de bien vous avez l'air
plus humble là vachement
va tomber sur Paris vous quand même des
précautions oratoires
c'est la première la première
proposition que j'ai eu après cette
histoire c'est la lessive tu m'étonnes
du même nom qui voulait que je fasse la
publicité j'ai demandé trop d'argent ah
bon
vous êtes beaucoup plus prudent
aujourd'hui vous publiez un livre de
recommandation et pas un livre de
prédiction alors ça s'appelle le fil
d'Ariane donc laisse-toi guider chez
Michel Lafont le pitch c'est tout est
signe et tout signe et porteur de sens
on est pas seul abandonné parce que
chaque fois les gens me disent ah
j'aurais que des malheurs de ma vie j'ai
des tas de problèmes je me sens
abandonné tout ça non il ouvre les yeux
regarde le ciel nous envoie des
avertissements il faut simplement on
n'en tient pas toujours compte
du logis et l'ouvrir son cœur c'est à
dire l'intuition
donc votre situation vous amenez sur ce
plateau ce soir
un jour il m'a eu d'une façon au 18e
siècle 18e siècle c'est quand il est
venu m'interviewer dans mon bureau et
avec un roi d'Espagne à l'époque
et un moment sur le sujet de
réincarnation et il dit qu'est-ce que
vous avez été dans le passé et moi je
lui raconte naïvement parce qu'il avait
rangé ce Magnéto et c'était pas vrai il
était toujours ouvert il raconte au 18e
j'étais [__] et que je faisais des
arcades du du Palais Royal et que là le
roi Louis XV de bien-aimé j'étais 5
clientes et ni avant et c'est qui le 15
maintenant je dis c'est balader
et moi et attendez après 15 jours après
il a sucé balader
me dit sans voix des fax de bureau dans
tous les ministères
achète interview et j'avais pas regardé
interview j'ajoute Paco rabat je me suis
fait baiser par baladure oh 18e siècle
c'est ça la presse
aux fleurs pendant 40 ans je faisais
partie des meubles du Flore pendant 40
ans j'étais aux fleurs depuis la des
années 50 et j'étais en train de manger
ma salade dans le bout de la terrasse et
brusquement du côté de l'église
Saint-Germain de près je vois quatre
malabars qui viennent comme ça avec au
milieu un titre sautillant comme ça il y
a des chaussettes rouges et il passe il
s'arrête devant moi le gars se retourne
lui dit bonjour monsieur rabat Edouard
va la dur non non Didier Gustin
de la terrasse lycée Paco il a encore
envie de te baiser
c'est une histoire vraie c'était quoi
dans une autre vie toi Orlando
bien alors le livre débute avec une
histoire incroyable survenu à votre mère
et à vous à Saint-Sébastien en 1939 vous
allez prendre un bateau pour fuir
l'Espagne mon père était général
républicain et commandait à Guernica le
premier général pris par Franco est
fusillé par Franco à santonia souris et
les troupes fascistes enfin frankiste
entouré ça Sébastien il y avait un
bateau qui partait pour le Mexique et ma
mère de ses quatre enfants et ma
grand-mère on monte sur le bateau et au
moment où le capitaine veut lever la
passerelle ma mère hurle non non faut
pas rester ici il faut elle redescend
sur le quai et le capitaine lui dit
Madame c'est le dernier bateau qui part
et il savait que ma mère était
recherchée par par la police et c'est
une femme politique importante
et le bateau s'en va de la rade de
Saint-Sébastien les avions arrivent le
bombarde et le bateau coule tout le
monde tuait et nous on a eu la chance à
paysan qui est passé par là a reconnu ma
mère nous a il y avait une camionnette
on nous a mis dans le parmi les pommes
de terre les légumes et on est passé
comme ça à travers les les lignes
franquistes jusqu'à Barcelone
l'intuition ma mère qui était une femme
de raison elle a un moment à ce
moment-là devant le danger elle a ouvert
de l'intuition ce jeudi aux gens soyez
intuitif c'est comme l'envoyer
qui met la ceinture ce jour-là
où tu as un pressentiment un truc faut
pas que tu le fasses et
comme d'habitude
les 48 heures avant avec 24 heures avant
avec Dominique desmer je me rappelle que
j'avais dîné la veille donc le 2 mai
avec Dominique et tandis qu'il habitait
à l'époque loin de Paris il avait dormi
à la maison
et puis on a parlé d'elle et puis
j'avais dit non si Dalida n'aimait pas
de l'ordre dans sa vie privée je perds
que je fasse de nouveau voilà et quand
je disais ces mots-là elle était déjà
rentrée dans le coma ça ça arrive ça
on sait pas on ressent des choses
ou des fois on a juste un sentiment mais
c'est parfois que ce sentiment devient
pressentiment parce que c'est confirmé
par un événement c'est peut-être ça non
on a un truc qui est génial c'est un
trésor que Dieu nous a remis entre les
mains c'est le libre arbitre la
possibilité de dire oui de dire non
d'aller à droite d'aller à gauche c'est
pour ça que je dis aux gens ne
rentraient surtout pas dans une secte
car les dégoûts
vont vous piquer votre lit Barbie vous
allez être des moutons le libramide
c'est la chose qui peut vous permettre à
tout moment de sauver votre vie et
d'échapper à des malheurs à des choses
il faut suivre cette instinct c'est très
important
au resto hier j'ai commandé des
escargots et j'ai senti que j'allais
payer de la gueule toute la soirée avant
de les manger tu vois une intuition
vous dites Paco en fait on est pas seul
il y a beaucoup de messagers célestes et
sans arrêt les séraphins les chérubins
les Archanges les anges les Chronopost
qui n'a pas été créé par hasard et
protégé par quatre élémentaux par des
forces de nature ce sont les les noms de
la terre les ondins de l'eau les rafales
de l'air et les salamandres du feu et
c'est quatre éléments protègent la
planète Terre de toutes les conneries
qui peuvent survenir et surtout que
l'homme fait subir à la planète Terre tu
as dit quoi non salamandre on peut les
voir moi les légumes de la terre qui
sont des êtres rouges on peut les voir à
partir le soir qu'on soit tombe et pour
ça il faut ouvrir son coeur
jamais fumer
et jamais pris de drogue parce que je
suis puritain crevé vérifie la clim chez
toi quand même ils doivent t'envoyer le
truc
dans le Léon danseur là vous avez fait
l'amour avec la terre c'est là que j'ai
fait l'amour
40 il a fait son premier voyage astral à
l'âge de 7 ans avec un curé
j'avais 12 ans j'avais envie de baiser
dans le lit on peut pas aller 40 il y
avait une puritanisme terrible c'était
le planétaire le mois d'août j'ai fait
un trou dans la lande
j'ai baisé le sol et quand j'ai joué
dans le sol la terre a trembler c'est
vrai il y a exactement flash de lumière
il y a eu un flash de lumière et j'ai
été enivré par les odeurs les odeurs de
jeunesse
la vérité c'est qu'il a rien poussé
derrière
non et vraiment la terre ils étaient
enivré par toutes les odeurs de la
langue et j'ai appris bien plus tard que
c'était une épreuve d'initiation en
Afrique dans certaines tribus et moi je
l'ai fait d'instin la première chose que
j'ai besoin monde c'était la Gaia même
beaucoup
c'est normal mais j'ai baisé la terre et
à 12 ans elle te le rend bien maintenant
c'est sûr alors il y a plein il y a
plein d'anecdotes dans le livre de Paco
il y a celle des de l'ange gardien à
Saint-Germain-des-Prés là c'était
c'était fameuse histoire où ce pauvre
Pierre Perret sort de de Bobino il avait
fait son spectacle il y a 3 mecs qui
s'approchent de lui 17 fois père Perret
et dites lui très naïf très gentil oui
oui et les mecs d'envoyer à l'hôpital
pour six mois mâchoire fracturé dans un
état pitoyable et moi je sortais de de
l'Alcazar du temps de de rivière et de
Nice et de donuts et je vois les trois
types qui s'approchent comme ça que
c'était 2h du matin et j'entends dans ma
tête une sonnerie mais une sonnerie
insensible et je dis là Paco danger et
surtout quand j'étais seul il y a
personne à rue je n'ai pas changé de
trottoir j'ai foncé le droit sur eux en
disant Paco danger les gars arrive
sûrement dit j'ai pas par contre j'ai
dit ah non j'en ai comprenne pour ce con
excuse-nous et ils sont passés j'aurais
dit oui Marie va la même mésaventure
pour se marrer
pour en parler dans banlieue c'est votre
ange gardien qui ce soir-là vous a dit
exactement ne dites pas que vous êtes
d'accord exactement il faut pas que je
dise ça parce que il faut écouter ce
soir on sait jamais
je vous donne un truc pour voir les
anges gardiens oui bon regardez fixement
comme ça
droit quand vous êtes chez vous que
calmement et ne bougez pas les yeux et
essayez alors que vous regardez tout
droit essayez de regarder ici sur la
gauche et faites-le souvent il faut
aller voir apparaître cet Être de
Lumière comme ça qui va passer le
lendemain devant vous ça s'appelle la
cataracte et il y a pas
oh
non ça s'opère c'est rien du tout
homme de deux fois il faut avoir cette
espèce d'écoute intérieur quand je dis
que l'être le plus important pour vous
sur la planète Terre c'est vous-même tu
as des enfants et non c'est pour ça que
je dis ça
j'en ai rien à voir un jeune homme tout
de la planète Terre c'est mes enfants et
dans ce chakra
et dans ce coeur du cœur
il réside là c'est intuition qu'il faut
faire naître c'est tout ce qui est bien
en tous les cas dans votre bouquin Paco
Rabanne c'est que vous mettez les gens
en garde contre les charlatans il faut
faire très grave très très gaffe
moi je porte le témoignage parce que je
suis arrivé à 72 ans à la fin de mes
vies et j'ai envie de porter
78000 ans je suis sur cette planète
Terre depuis 78000 ans parce que je suis
arrivé de la constellation de lait de
l'Aigle de l'étoile bleue Altaïr tu vas
toucher la première Atlantide mais ça
c'est une histoire qu'il faudrait elle
est où la première Atlantide alors elle
était là-bas dans les Barbades
et c'est pas le Sahara
voilà ça s'appelle le fil d'Ariane c'est
publié chez Michel Lafont
Paco Rabanne on va vérifier ce on croit
vous croyez on va faire une interview
croyante
[Musique]
Paco est-ce que vous croyez en vous oui
est-ce que vous croyez en Dieu oui je
l'ai vu trois fois Harry je l'ai vu je
l'ai vu quand il n'auriez pas
quand j'ai eu 20 ans pendant
une partie de foot
sur la touche au stade Pershing c'était
un soleil colossal j'étais projeté là où
j'ai devant ce soleil comme ça tous les
20 ans j'ai cette privilège de le voir
et la deuxième fois la deuxième fois
c'était une immense spirale rouge était
dans un taxi bloqué place de la Concorde
et j'ai entendu cette voix qui me disait
veux-tu me voir encore j'ai dit oui mais
c'était c'était toujours tu arrives à
placer la Concorde
et moi j'ai dit oui mais à l'intérieur
sauf que le chauffeur de taxi de taxi
n'entendrent rien et c'est arrivé une
seconde je parle avec Dieu
et j'étais proche j'étais pas de
sacrilège vous allez avoir des pépins
dans votre vie
si il fait le signe de la croix
non je ris pas de toi j'aime bien quand
tu voulais vous avez le droit de vous
[__] de ma gueule
ça fait peur fais pas les gros yeux mais
ne faites pas ne faisons est-ce que vous
est-ce que vous suivez là est-ce que
vous même moi j'ai du mal mais je pense
à aucun moment qui se moque de Monsieur
on peut le revoir les images
comme nous n'avons pas eu la chance
d'avoir vécu cette expérience dans une
taxi en place
on a le droit de se renseigner quand
même bien sûr bien sûr tacos est-ce que
vous croyez c'est une reine anglaise une
reine anglaise
est-ce que vous croyez que les femmes
simulent parfois
je pense que oui parfois parfois
rarement mais parfois et si vous croyez
au trèfle à quatre feuilles aux pattes
de lapin touche du bois tout ça vous
croyez pas vous croyez aux anges
gardiens oui
les extraterrestres j'en ai vu ah bon
dans un bus on essaye
des gens qui passent qui traversent la
vie en regardant leurs chaussures ou le
sol c'est toujours les gens tous les
gens qui ont des problèmes de fric ou
des problèmes de mal d'être regardent
toujours le solver vérifier les gens
dans la rue et il y a les autres les
poètes qui regardent le ciel et quand
vous relevez le regard vers le ciel vous
voyez des choses auxquelles pour un
poteau il y a deux possibilités
la créature de Roswell c'est une vraie
ah oui quand on le sait ça parce que
allez pas à l'époque il y a eu des
nouvelles choses mais pourquoi pourquoi
Truman
comme par hasard avec
Rockefeller ont-ils créé la CIA comme
par hasard en 47 tout de suite après le
crash de Roswell on est con donc Pradel
avait raison oui il existe Pradel je
n'ai vu à la télé
est-ce que vous croyez au marabout non
au bout de ficelle un astrologie on joue
pas personnellement
par exemple Françoise Hardy le fait très
bien très bien vous êtes de quel signe
vous Verseau
comme Mozart
ah je sais pas mais en même temps comme
Giscard
c'est lequel qui joue de la musique
oui j'en ai eu beaucoup mais sympa il y
en a des sympas ils sont tous sympas il
y en a qui sont bloqués c'est vrai
qu'ils sont bloqués
au moment où vous mourrez ils aiment
tellement la vie ils s'accroche à la vie
donc il se décatage pas du corps et il
s'accroche au meubles au lieu et ma
nièce qui a 5 ans on a vu comme moi mais
plusieurs j'avais un château de Château
de Palio
pourquoi il y a pas de fantôme
vous verrez dans un endroit brusquement
dans une pièce fermée vous allez voir
les meubles qui tombent le chat qui se
dresse hérissé et qui regarde comme si
quelqu'un passait dans la pièce car les
chats voient des fantômes et vous les
protège les gens et moi j'avais ce
château de talio on peut pas dormir dans
une chambre car les portes claquées se
refermaient les tiroirs sautés et même
des dégâts qui étaient vraiment très
pragmatique ils n'ont pas pu dormir dans
cette chambre et au milieu de la nuit
sont levés en hurlant de terreur parce
que il y avait cette phénomène mais
personnellement
[Musique]
vous croyez au vampire non non ah c'est
marrant ça
c'est une histoire inventée
est-ce que vous croyez au journal
télévisé ah je suis fervent
le plus un vrai semblable qui soit
est-ce que vous croyez à l'effet des
crèmes anti-rides
plus dur déjà non mes sœurs ont comme
moi une peau par idée parce que notre
grand-mère nous avait appris à nous
laver sans savon jamais jamais de savon
à l'eau chaude l'eau bouillante
le gant de toilette trempé dans le
bouillon que vous passez sur le visage
jamais de savon mes sœurs n'ont pas une
ride elles ont plus de peau non plus
elles sont magnifiques
qui maintient la peau
après la fidélité dans le couple
et oui oui j'en connais beaucoup
mes sœurs par exemple combien de temps
ressorts
ça fait quoi ça fait déjà 45 ans 45 ans
sans baiser ailleurs non se sont mariés
vierge elles étaient vierges n'avaient
pas touché un garçon
j'ai mon ange gardien qui m'envoie un
texto là
merci beaucoup vous êtes au top amitié
sincère Lolo Boyer merci mon Lolo
alors est-ce que vous croyez au sexe
sans amour
c'est ce qui se passe aujourd'hui ça
s'appelle la baise ah bon et c'est ça
oui
on fait de l'amour avec la femme que
l'on aime et on baise les filles de
rencontres c'est totalement différent et
c'était donc c'est un sexe sans amour
moi je comprends pas pourquoi on vous
file pas le ministère de l'éducation
nationale
est-ce que vous croyez par exemple que
l'argent ne fait pas le bonheur l'argent
peut être la chose la plus dangereuse
exemple le loto avec ces sommes
insensées et combien de gens se sont
suicidés par ce qu'ils ont eu trop de
fric et ils n'ont pas su gérer cet
argent il y a quand même beaucoup plus
de gens qui se sont suicidés parce
qu'ils en avaient pas si on voit
les chiffres je crois pas ça vous croyez
que les drogues douces conduisent
forcément en drogues dures
obligatoirement j'en ai trop connu je
suis quand même une génération qui a vu
naître toutes les drogues tous les
années 70 au tout les drogues LSD est
arrivé Mike Brant qui se lance dans dans
le dessus sa terrasse en croyant qui
était un oiseau et tous les mecs qui me
disaient aujourd'hui pas ça oh moi
j'arrêterai quand je voudrais on les
retrouvait mort d'une verre d'eau dans
les chiottes de l'Alcazar non non ils
ont commencé par des choses douces ils
ont affaires par les drogues dures et
ils sont donc pas de drôle du tout
non un bon vin non l'amour un verre
est-ce que vous croyez à l'innocence de
Michael Jackson
non non c'est-à-dire arriver à une telle
grande gloire
il ne sait plus où le moral s'arrête
doit s'arrêter c'est à dire pour lui
étant de Michael Jackson c'est-à-dire un
dieu vivant la plus de repère et donc il
croit qu'il peut faire tout ce qu'il
veut que personne ne le reprochera
jamais rien
est-ce que vous me croyez si je vous dis
que je vous crois
vous passez pour un être un peu
démoniaque dans le sens dans le sens
simplement que vous avez un verbe assez
terrifiant que vous savez un peu
déshabiller l'âme des gens et mais au
fond de vous-même il y a un
c'est ça doit venir d'une d'un atavisme
racial il y a un être qui a vécu
beaucoup de choses et par vos
réincarnations vous avez
une personnalité extraordinaire dans le
passé c'était quoi avant les j'étais
j'ai eu deux au moins deux vies que je
connais il y en a une où j'étais un
galérien je ramène sur une galère
c'était horrible dans l'Antiquité
gréco-romaine et une autre vie au
moyen-âge où j'attaque un château fort
et je prends un boulet dans le ventre
j'en suis persuadé
rien à voir et pour être sûr de ne rien
rater de innarditude abonnez-vous et
mettez un pouce bleu